as we were saying I'm Brian Curtis
editor-at-large of the ringer on behalf
of the Texas Tribune I'm happy to
welcome you to the seventh annual Texas
Tribune Festival and to Trump and the
presidency a very rich panel I believe
there is a hole in this what we what we
call this tract there's a whole bunch of
panels today Trump in national security
Trump in Congress Trump and the
resistance we hope you'll make this the
first of a huge day here at the festival
there's lunch on the main mall and at
the day will conclude with a reception
at the AT&T Center a few more
housekeeping things this panel is
supported by Pearson and the sponsors
and donors underwrite this event but
they play no role in determining the
content the panelists or my line of
questioning this event will be 60
minutes the last 15 to 20 I'll leave it
open for your questions from the
audience for this fabulous panel and
after that Pearson will be hosting all
of us for a brief meet and greet next
door in the community hub of the Texas
Union Building where we will all drain
the swamp together so please join us for
that also if you're going to tweet
during this event your hashtag is trip
fest 17 and while you're looking at your
phone please silence it with that said
let me introduce our panelists first two
to my left is Douglas Brinkley he's a
professor at Rice he has CNN's
presidential historian and and the
author of several books about the
presidency most recently rightful
heritage Franklin D Roosevelt and the
land of America Mar Eliassen next to him
is the national political correspondent
for NPR where she has covered every
presidential election since 1992
you can hear her on shows like all
things considered in morning edition and
she's also a contributor to Fox News and
to her left HW brands as a historian and
writer who holds the jack s Blanton
senior chair in history here at UT he is
also the author of several books about
the presidency most recently the general
versus the president MacArthur and
Truman at the brink of nuclear war and
as some of you have seen this the writ
materials we were supposed to be it's
supposed to be joined by Dan Rather
today but he was unable to come in
anyway the four of us are going to carry
on in his absence today okay let's start
with an innocent time in history
Doug December president-elect Trump as
he was then known had you as one of his
guests for a lunch at mar-a-lago where
he talked about the presidency the
office he was about to inhabit what did
Donald Trump talk about at that lunch
well it was he was present and elect and
I'm the historian for a presidential
historian for CNN and he was just
starting to have his war with CNN so
when I first met him he did not have
nice things to say about my network and
then I got to talk to him about the
presidency and I asked him about
presidents that he's met in his life his
personal relationship with thin he had
told me about how Jimmy Carter how he
had given money to anybody to defeat
Jimmy Carter in 1980 that he thought
Carter was a terrible president and to
his surprise after the election Carter
came to see him made an appointment and
wanted money from Trump for his new
Carter Center and he said I really
admired Jimmy Carter now that he had the
Hood spa that come on and
and to go look you know come I ball to
eyeball even though I I didn't like him
and ask for money Nixon did he say if he
gave the money part did he say some
shady no he would not get on anything
and then he said with Richard Nixon that
he became very friendly with Nixon cuz
he was on the Phil Donahue show and Pat
Nixon saw Trump and she said honey
that's gonna be a President of the
United States is on the Donahue show and
then he got a letter from Nixon which he
willingly shows people President Trump
from Richard Nixon saying my wife said
she never saw somebody as smart and
great as you on TV let's go out for for
a meal and they started dining regularly
together Trump and Nixon the remember
Nixon was in his reputation wasn't a
turd he was living in northern New
Jersey trying to get back in the game
and Donald Trump in the 1980s was on
covers of magazines as the big New York
Builder so you could make some more
sense why Nixon may have tried to do a
reach out like that to him stories like
that it talked about Reagan and why he
likes about Reagan Sally
it wasn't anything deeply illuminating
however we talked about inaugural
speeches and he had not prepared yet and
knew nothing about them and he just kept
saying I want to be short I want to be
short and I told him about William Henry
Harrison going long and dying he after
after only one month and we talked about
Kennedy's in the like but it was pretty
a innocuous a meaning I might take away
was that he had almost zero
understanding of American history that
he somebody of a child of television and
operates with gut instinct of what he
sees
he's very visual we now all know how
much he watches cable and all that I
think that is his intellectual source is
cable news but the he may have a short
attention span so the idea that he'd
read a book that you know HW brands book
for example and not going to happen
Doug did he seem surprised that he had
one yeah he seems
surprised that he had one in the sense
that he kept spinning this idea that
there was voter fraud of that they you
need that Hillary didn't really win by
three million because three million
illegal people voted and I was a little
startled that he was clinging to that
false narrative he'd won so you might as
well be magnanimous I will say this was
this weird moment in a time in histories
everything I don't know whether he knew
whether he was going to do repeal and
replace Obamacare or do infrastructure I
think a that I think the betting money
was he was going to do repealing replace
Obama care I think when general Flynn
got busted at and this was you know
going and really he started recognizing
he was going to be under investigation
Trump that his instinct was to double
down with his base and I think that pipe
dream that maybe he was like a third way
wasn't really a Democrat or a Republican
and he might try to do bipartisan things
I that evaporated quickly and he just
did red meat for the that so-called
Trump base which is thirty five to forty
percent of the voting public a doubling
down that that all the way through last
night in Alabama when he's talking about
the NFL and Colin Kaepernick at a at a
rally that is putative Lee to to endorse
to endorse and support a Senate
candidate Mara we're eight months into
the Trump administration doesn't it seem
like eight hundred months but what do
you have a sense at this point of how
Trump regards the institution of the
presidency which is a topic of this
panel that's a really good question I
think that he views the institution of
the presidency as definitely not a
co-equal branch of government he as a I
think he sees it as a super equal branch
of government I think he's been
frustrated that he didn't get the kind
of respect you know he's not venerated
in the way he'd like to the fact that he
loved that military parade so much in
France and talks about have wanting to
have one here the kind of leaders you
know authoritarian anti-democratic
that he respects and bonds with around
the world tells you a little bit about
how he views his role and I guess as a
journalist when I started when Trump
came into office I kept a couple
questions in my mind one was is Donald
Trump different in degree or kind from
previous presidents in other words is he
just a ruder cruder conservative
Republican or is he something wholly new
and different and I started out thinking
he was ruder and cruder and I'm coming
around to thinking in many ways he's
different in kind you know his view of
other democratic institutions like the
independent judiciary the press the
things he feels the norms he feels
totally comfortable breaking I don't
think he even sees them as norms I think
he is different in kind and I I do see
Donald Trump as a stress test for
democratic institutions and that's
something that I think is the big story
of his presidency you know will the
independent judiciary survive intact the
press is under tremendous pressure not
just from Donald Trump obviously and so
those are things I'm watching for but I
think he sees the presidency in a
different way than any other prep any
other modern president and I love to
hear what the presidential historians
think about this but he will described
his inauguration as I took an oath to
the American people not to the
Constitution I don't think he thinks
about the Constitution I don't think he
feels he has any restraints on him as a
matter of fact the thing says he has
talked about with such glee is how when
I'm president I can't do anything
illegal you know what's this it was it
was kind of the Nixon phrases if I do it
it has to be legal but what I forget
what how he put it but something like
the president can't have a conflict
right you know so I think he sees it as
like as so many things in his life has
been as a big fat get-out-of-jail-free
card I don't mean that literally
what do you bill as a presidential
historian has who is someone who has
seen who has studied how different man
to the state in history regard the
institution how would you say the Trump
regards well I would say looks honored
as a businessman there's a reason that
Donald Trump is the only person to talk
to the elected president who's the top
line on the resume was businessman and
the only other sort of really successful
business person to become president was
Herbert Hoover who's not a really good
advertisement for being a great
president but I think what Mario just
described this in patients with the
constraining institutions goes very much
in line with the impatience that a CEO
would have the fundamental difference
between business and politics is that in
business you can fire the people who are
causing you trouble but the president
can't he can't fire the Senate Majority
Leader he can't fire the Supreme Court
he has to live with them and Trump is
running up against this and as someone
who is brand new to politics
he hasn't apparently accepted this and
I'm not sure that the age of 71 he's
inclined to change his ways I think he
still hopes that he can change the
institutions rather than have the
institutions change him we've all been
processing the flurry of news over the
eight last first date will first eight
months of this administration I just I
can think of nothing else but going and
with a Twitter open and with the phone
and tell my wife did you just see what
Donald Trump just said but since you
guys are paid to imagine the
unimaginable Doug what what has gone as
you expected about these first eight
months and what has what is different
well getting Neil courser chin to the
Supreme Court as as expected
he was going to pick a conservative and
that's going to have a lasting impact
thus far I see it as his biggest success
in 2017 I thought that the Twitter use
might get toned down I had a fantasy
that he Banco would be like the
Twitter's are and at any time he was
about to push send he would make a deal
with her that she would have to read it
first and she'd let 90% of them go out
or 95% but once in a while saying not
that
not that one not that one that obviously
hasn't happened
you know the bellick III just the
determination to keep in flaming and
dividing the country all presidents come
in and try to unite you know john f
kennedy's first a hundred days
ostensibly as bill and certainly knows
was a bit of a failure they have pigs
happen in the first 100 days uriga
garyun that cosmonauts going in the
space with russia but by a meeting hit
Kennedy went and said I screwed up the
Bay of Pigs in Cuba don't blame Ike I
did it he had a 77 percent approval
rating after his first 100 days bias
after his first year in office John F
Kennedy had an 80 percent approval
rating a that's not gonna happen with
Donald Trump he's just as you mentioned
last night in Alabama wherever he goes
he's polarizing he feels he's winning in
a divide-and-conquer way and you know I
worked out books on Reagan before and
Reagan used to say you've got to have
50% a box office to get something done
meaning your polls got to be 50 51 in
order to push a policy through trumps
constantly operating with 35 to 40
percent and hence nothing's getting done
but he steals the headline news every
day because of Twitter and by playing
this cultural war game like we saw a
Charlotte bill what you're seeing with
football last night he's in an in I find
it a bit reprehensible because it's
pitting American against American in
order to kind of you know be in charge
and they some of the lambing it all
began with this birther movement on
Obama than the building of the wall and
the chanting of it and making
mexican-americans Latino and Latinas
feel like lesser people by not reviewed
not having a meeting with somebody like
John Lewis to talk about civil rights
and he's so we're any really serious
unprecedented as we say on CNN all the
time moment
where we've got a president that's gone
rogue on us rogue on our institutions
going he's trying anytime he can to
circumvent the law and he just knows
that he's got an inoculation as long as
he can keep about 40 percent of a
population backing anything that he does
the Muller report in my opinion could
come out tomorrow and short of being
something so egregious that Trump does
the his that 35 or 40% will shrugged him
and stay with him because they've signed
on to the cult of Donald Trump the
persona of Donald Trump the people that
I've talked to and some are probably
here in the audience that are most
frustrated Trump are conservatives
they're feeling like my god we've been
working in the conservative movement for
decades and this is the result this is
what's been produced and so things are
the political occurrence right now are
vicious and confused but I think it all
gets back to the 1960s and early 70s
Reagan used to say I'm trying to roll
back the Great Society I think Trump if
he had his way we'd like to roll back
the Great Society and and the New Deal
if he could about you Mar what would has
surprised you of all the surprises well
I guess what surprised me is that Donald
Trump is exactly as he was during the
campaign in other words there was some
kind of weird magical thinking that this
was all an act that he used to be a
Democrat that he would revert to this
kind of theory the alternative universe
of Donald and theory of you Donald Trump
is what Doug just suggested that because
he was so unique that he could bust the
partisan boundaries and he'd do a big
infrastructure deal with the Democrats
and he wasn't a conservative Republican
but that you know totally went by the
wayside and he did choose a strict base
strategy and he did subcontract out his
legislative agenda to the Republican
leadership in Congress much to his
dismay over time because they haven't
delivered they came in and said don't
worry mr. president we'll repeal and
replace Obamacare and have
reformed by August you know and that's
why he's so angry but a couple thoughts
number one he he might have a thirty
five percent approval rating but as we
all learned during the campaign national
approval rating doesn't mean that much
national poll numbers don't mean that
much what we want to know is what is his
approval rating in the ten battleground
states and when you talk to people in
the White House they believe his
approval rating is not thirty five
percent that he's still about where he
was when he got elected they think he's
in the forties and quite frankly he
could be a legislatively completely
unsuccessful president and get nothing
through except for Neel Gorsuch and a
bunch of regulated deregulation which in
and of itself could be fine but he could
win reelection he could be politically
successful because all you have to do to
win elections in America is win one vote
win by one vote in those battleground
states he could get a smaller percentage
of the popular vote and still pull out
an electoral college victory and I think
that's why he pays such a meticulous
attention to the base but in terms of
conservatives looking with the dismay on
Donald Trump what happened yesterday in
Alabama was really interesting not just
the incredible 90-minute screed which is
you know we probably should go back and
watch that just for all of its various
detours that he took but he was
campaigning for a candidate Luther
strange that his base doesn't like and
what that trip to Alabama was a test for
whether the Trump bases loyalty to Trump
and you know he once famously said I can
stand on Fifth Avenue and shoot someone
and I wouldn't lose any voters and his
base has been described as a cult of
personality but there are many
Republicans who say the cult of
personality isn't as big as people think
it is and it's not as strong as people
think it is and they're gonna come to
the rally with Trump
laughing applauded all his applause
lines and they're gonna go out and
they're gonna vote for Roy Moore the guy
he was ostensibly campaigning against
the here's here's a quote from that
relic but is this such a fascinating
thing this happens to be about Colin
Kaepernick it could be about any number
of things
with with the president but this is this
is him talking about
we saw him tweeting about the Emmy
Awards this week and this is him Tweety
this is him talking excuse me about an
NFL owner with a player who was kneeling
during the national anthem he is now
doing the voice he says quote get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field right now
out he's fired he's fired what bill what
do you think is the purpose in Donald
Trump's mind of going there with that
particular topic in that kind of
language in that venue from the very
beginning of the Donald Trump phenomenon
I've wondered to what extent the actions
that he takes are calculated and to what
extent they're simply impulsive and the
more I watch and the more I think it's
simply impulsive I'm not sure that he
had a purpose I'm not even sure that he
knew he was going to say that when he
stepped up to the mic that he just
started in and then he's wandered off I
think this is one of the reasons that
the people around him are at least so
far unable to rein him in because they
they don't know what he's gonna do and
when he's going to do it he's one of the
remarkable things to me about President
Trump is that he is exactly like he was
during the campaign for everybody else
there's kind of a candidate discount
that you take into account when they
change from candidate to be president
because they realize these are two
different roles but with President Trump
there doesn't seem to be any
differentiation and the first signal is
when you win in the election and then
when you give your Naugle address and
everybody else before Trump has followed
the Thomas Jefferson model after the
very divisive 1800 election we're
referring to the two major parties of
those days he said we are all
Republicans we are all federalist but
Trump made no gesture at all in that
direction and one of the questions that
posed tomorrow is if Donald Trump has to
choose between getting something done
let's say tax reforms where he has to
cut deals with the Democrats he has to
choose between that and hanging on to
his base would he rather get reelected
with essentially no legislative
accomplishments or get the legislative
accomplishments and
perhaps jeopardize his position with his
base get reelected yeah no doubt yeah no
doubt in my mind and because one of the
questions that occurs to me is what does
he want out of the presidency nearly
everybody else I mean everybody else who
gets elected president realizes first of
all this is the biggest thing they've
ever done because they've all been in
public service before and they at least
have some idea of what they want to
accomplish or how they want to be seen
when they're out of all this with
President Trump I cannot figure that out
and for all I know
his major goal is to make his net worth
greater at the end of his time in office
than it is now well he wants to get good
headlines he wants to get as party like
he wanted to get good poll numbers but
in terms of and he wants to be the
greatest president that America has ever
seen but that's not I don't think he
believes that that is dependent on
something he accomplished as an office
he could just go out and tell people
that right and they and they would
believe it but can I say one one thing
that has one thing maybe that we had
worse that have been surprised that a
little bit okay the the real concern of
many people during the campaign was that
he meant what he said when he said NATO
was obsolete and maybe we should you
know pull back from our role in NATO he
didn't like multilateral alliances you
know the whole kind of isolationist
pro-putin now that was a surprise he
didn't he didn't he was stopped by other
democratic institutions from having the
kind of relationship with Russia that I
think he wanted and he even though he
was dragged kicking and screaming he did
finally affirm article 5 of NATO you
know an attack on one is an attack on
all so what is jokingly called in
Washington the committee to save America
which is Tillerson mattis McMaster and
Kelly they have constrained him so in
other words his at least in foreign
policy his bark is a lot worse than his
bite you know one day he goes up and
says we're gonna destroy North Korea the
next day oh just some more sanctions
right um what one day being Thursday one
day be literally the next last yeah yeah
the next day he cut with sanctions you
know he's gonna pull out of the Iran
deal it was the most embarrassing thing
ever
the next day well we're gonna try to
negotiate some addendums to it so I
think that has been that that has been
reassuring certainly to a lot of
Republicans who are on the ledge around
Donald Trump but as long as you've got
that national security team you know the
committee to save America intact and as
a matter of fact apparently secretary
mattis's he travels around the world
called success as a joke I'm here on the
secretary of reassurance but I don't
want to make it like Donald Trump is
just a lone ranger
he's us yeah he's representing America
he's taken the low-hanging fruit to win
you know in 1992 nineteen percent of the
public voted for Ross Perot 19% Pro got
a 92 on anti-nafta that's always been a
bit of a swing vote crowd he grabbed it
George Wallace after Lyndon Johnson did
the Civil Rights Acts in 64 and 65 got
powerful in Alabama where we're talking
about he won the south when he ran for
presidency in 68 picked up States on a
racist of Berkeley racist platform
George Wallace ran on he had Strom
Thurmond and the Dixiecrats of Barry
Goldwater on a kind of Newcombe back to
the Stone Age
Richard Nixon in his silent majority and
some people that just vote are they just
can't stand Democrats and liberals so
he's created a whack pack of a coalition
but but it was all these strands he was
able to keeping it at all his whole
presence he is trying to keep that
together for what they suggested
reelection he plays to win it to him
it's about winning and were right he
never he left the campaign why stop
campaigning I'm keep running he also
gets an R in our Cystic feed from the
crowds and he needs that because if you
read about people
those malignant self-love in a
narcissistic disorder they can't handle
too much negativity well he's gonna
watch cable he's gonna get a dose load
of a negativity and he erupts about it
because here but he gets his high by
going to Alabama and saying just the
thing that will bring the house down and
basically brought racial politics into a
you know in Alabama on attacking you
know in the NFL player that's Donald
Trump and so I think he's nativist
xenophobic and race based dog whistles
is quiet and it's a businessman that
doesn't like a lot of federal
regulations because they stopped him
from building some projects and he has
the typical
gripe of builders about and developers
that you know they could have put the
building up two years sooner but one for
all that government red tape after
charlottesville when Trump equivocated
between the Nazis protesters and the
counter protesters who shut up Marv you
went on NPR and said he doesn't see his
job as president as providing moral
leadership to the country this is very
different from any every other modern
president when faced with a racial
episode like this so can you be
President of the United States and be a
moral if that's the right word on a
topic like Charlottesville do you have
to provide moral leadership well he is
the president of the United States and
he's not providing moral leadership so I
guess the answer to that question is yes
but that was an amazing moment because
the easiest thing for presidents is to
it's almost like control-f delete
whatever it's called default on your
keyboard what you say after a moment of
racial tension it's like in the in the
memory bank you just stand up and you
say some words of inclusion and healing
and even if you don't say them very
eloquently every other president has
said that there's a standard thing for
presidents to stay after an incident of
racial tension and he chose not to do
that and it turned out it was about him
because what happened was he they had
written a statement like that for him
which he did read off the teleprompter
but then he he just was mad and he
didn't either like the way it was
received or people accused him of
waiting too long
and so then he just let her rip you know
when he was in Trump Tower and you saw
those incredible images of John Kelly
the new chief of staff looking like he
you know like he wanted to sink through
the marble floor but that's that is how
he he does not see the president as
providing moral leadership he does see
the president as a cheerleader for
America and he said that during the
campaign and you can see when he goes
down to the hurricane areas for which he
got good remarks and that's what good
marks and that is why his poll numbers
ticked up a little bit he goes down
there and talks about how great
everything is and how great the relief
ever it is and how great it is we only
lost 33 people so he does see it as it
as a cheerleader and a Salesman um you
know he's always talking about how much
how many fighter planes some foreign
leader has decided to buy so he so he
does see his role in that way as a
booster but the other the question I
have for these two guys is do you think
after Donald Trump leaves office in four
or seven years there will be a move to
constrain the presidency in other words
one of the effects of Donald Trump will
be a diminishment of the powers of the
executive to make it a law that you have
to release your tax returns to actually
enshrine in law that you can't have
conflicts of interest things like that
because that's what happened after
Watergate not everything is written into
law all these norms that we hear about
you know I almost feel like there's some
guy named norm and he's being like
obliterated every day by Donald Trump
but there are all these things that
presidents just did and now Donald Trump
doesn't want to do any of them so I'm
wondering if the upshot of this is that
you know Franklin Roosevelt and 13 right
like that yeah 44 you do it
constitutional in there now we have two
terms there will be a kind of repost
Trump reflection and we'll have to see
how that plays out but we don't know at
this point whether it's
one-termer or tudor Moreau three years I
mean or a four term er I think it's all
a um a work in progress what is true is
he's been a great disrupter of American
history
I mean he's taking our times and
throwing it topsy-turvy in our business
we can't talk about anything else
because everything's Donald Trump 24/7
you've got almost as unplug and take a
walk and D Trump eyes yourself because
if he can drive you insane because he's
flippin not this is that and it's
keeping everybody off kilter and that
only plays I think into his hand but I
we were talking earlier they're very
likely he can win re-election I mean the
idea that the Democrats are going to
find a relative unknown who's going to
take on the guy's rip them down Trump is
a big brand and a and if you don't get
something like a Joe Biden or somebody
with a big brand and take him on it's a
hard season to build somebody up from a
grassroots to go up and knock him out so
the Democrats have to be careful on
their own process they're probably gonna
have about 15 candidates seeking the
presidency you might even have Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren running and
you're you know and then you Mitch
Landrieu Cory Booker Tim Ryan I mean the
the list um you know the list goes on
and on and not one right now looks like
maybe idea you're gonna create the Obama
character that's gonna come out of the
woodwork and then knock Donald Trump off
I'd be careful I think he's the stronger
political force than that you know can I
just one alternative theory to the idea
that Donald Trump is so overwhelming
he's so outrageous and he's constantly
tweeting and we have to react to
everything and we're you know 24 hours a
day Trump that's true but there's also a
completely opposite reaction that's
happening around the world which is they
don't listen to him because whatever he
says doesn't matter cuz he doesn't
follow through he doesn't do it you know
foreign leaders hear him say this and
they go and he's not gonna pull out of
NATO he's not going to pull out of the
you know the Iran nuclear deal and in
Congress I think that's happening a
little bit when he signed Congress did
something kind of amazing they passed
that Russia sanctions bill something
like 494 to zero or 98 to 2 he didn't
want it he was forced to sign it but he
he issued a signing statement he didn't
want more sanctions on Russia he wanted
the opposite but any when he issued a
signing statement about all the ways he
disagreed with this bill and somebody
asked bob Corker afterwards what do you
think of the president signing statement
he said whatever i mean for the chairman
of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee to say whatever about the
President of the United States and and
the way that that that Mitch McConnell
reacted to his making a deep and
tentative deal on daca with Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer you know he just said
well we look forward to seeing the
president's own legislative proposals I
mean they're starting as much as we're
obsessed with him we're starting people
are starting to tune him out also that's
the point I'm making that's a great
point and I saw that I edit a book
called the Nixon tapes so we had to go
through all of the Nixon tapes and the
media always picked on his curse
language or inflammatory language but
the thing that stuck out for me in the
Nixon tapes it's not like people would
just disregard it Kissinger at that he
was starting to unravel Nixon this is
Nixon of 73 and on the Nixon tapes in
1973 Kissinger be yes sir he'd be like
well but Jesus all of them
they would all just go yes sir right
away and they'd all nobody would follow
the order of the president and in a way
to make you feel if you're having
worries about Trump having his finger on
the nuclear button so to speak in the
North Korean crisis and ecard who's the
chief of staff of George W Bush told me
at the time of 9/11 he went out they
were there in Florida and Andy had to
come on stage if remember Bush was
reading my pet go to school kids and
Andy card had a whisper in his ear and
he kept kind of doing the thing and then
as soon as they got backstage a cluster
of government officials were there and
Bush said we're going right now
back to DC we got to get there now they
said you're not allowed to go we're not
letting you go to Washington and he in
Bush threw a tantrum it's I'm the
president we're going now let's go that
yeah we're not we're not allowing you
one way to get the government's not
allowing you you can't go into
Washington you were going to go to
Illinois easy Anna and then I the deep
state the state you were just saying how
people who always follows orders thought
that he's gonna tell Kelly in the near
rational moment tell them we're going I
want all all the the plan of the red
alert plan on or ain't gonna happen that
way they're gonna be brakes before
something largely irrational like that
it's done
I'd like to hike up on something that
back to me both Doug and Mara said and
I'll take issue with it a little bit I
think it's important to keep in mind
what President Trump has accomplished
and they're speaking as a historian
there are two things that historians are
going to be right about 20 years from
now regarding the Trump presidency and I
can guarantee this so we do have to
suspend judgment the presidency is not
completed but they're two things that
have happened already that are historic
one is he filled the ninth seat in the
Supreme Court with a 49 year old
conservative who might very well be
rendering conservative opinions 40 years
from now and so that's a big deal and
and I'll take a little bit issue with
what Mara said about but also confirming
what you just said the president has
single-handedly undermined American
leadership
in the world and this is something that
goes back to Franklin Roosevelt from
World War two until through the Obama
presidency every president of the United
States realized that it is important for
the United States to take world
leadership and the President of the
United States was the most important
single figure in world affairs that's
not the case now
because president Trump has basically
abdicated that role even if he
grudgingly affirms article 5 of NATO the
fact that he has to do it grudgingly
Angela Merkel is the leader of NATO now
if there is a leader and on you know the
world environment the president of China
is you know more progressive than the
president of the United States when
President Trump says one day he's going
to pull out of the Iran deal the next
day he's not for the last 75 years the
the word of the president of the new
United States was something pretty much
everybody else around the world would
take to the bank the word of this
president basically means nothing you
lose that you lose the confidence of the
world and it's really hard to get that
back well that's the question I have I
think a lot about this this stuff the
damage that he's doing to America's
standing in the world or the disruption
depending on your point of view is that
permanent or reparable I think it
matters whether it's four or eight years
but America is the world's greatest
Democratic superpower none of that goes
away we still have these democratic
institutions that he has not succeeded
in totally undermining yet so in a post
Trump world and I do believe the next
president his whole message will be I'm
not Donald Trump whoever it is whether
it's Mike Pence or anybody how much of
that can be repaired because America is
more than just one president I'm
confident in the United confident in the
United States that that could be
repaired
we that our country is built you know
all of our allies will come back to us
they just recognize we're having a weird
aberration going on here right now and
that there's just we have to all figure
it out they have their own problems in
their own some of these countries have
their own similar problems looking great
britain with brexit debate and all so
it's seen it's a confusing kind of
period of time but I think we can write
this shift in four years I do think if
Trump makes it for eight years it may do
some permanent damage but right now I
think we've earned enough credibility in
the world to be given a one offer within
that we our politics got out of control
particularly with the Russia scandal and
the Internet and Hillary Clinton won by
three million votes more and you know
all of this kind of it was a perfect
storm of confusion and this happens from
time to time in world history and I
think America will we'll get a pass on
in a couple of years that's very
optimistic but you know how American
leaders are always saying we separate
the Russian people from the Russian
leaders or the Iranian people we'd have
no grief with them now the world is
being asked to do that with us that
America equals / Donald Trump and son
are here with me and we were up in
Vancouver circulating a lot in Canada
and nobody was angry at the United
States for Trump they were more laughing
at us yeah that oh god you guys now phi
i'm glad they're not laughing at our
politicians yes America the but of the
world's humor but I think some of them
at least with their key allies is
good-natured right now and they're just
hoping we fix our our own house pretty
soon this is I mean this is the to
follow this strand do we think Donald
Trump has fundamentally changed the
institution of the presidency in eight
months now ready I think he's cheap and
cheap and it's cheap in the end I think
it used to be he's made the white house
seemed ticky-tacky he so it snowed seem
it's like it's things are up for sale
the lack of transparency on his taxes
the constantly being at mar-a-lago in
New Jersey eating up taxpayers money I
think there's like he's diminished it's
a shrinking role of what
Presidency means and that's not a
partisan statement because I think
Ronald Reagan did a wonderful job as a
Republican and George Herbert Walker
Bush and keeping a kind of institutional
lore the tradition of America we we're
country of traditions and he's just
thumbing his nose animal because they
don't fit his purposes or he hasn't
taken basic lessons and civility and
civics and how good government works and
so he's monkey trying to monkey wrench
things operating on paranoia as a fuel
calling the press the enemy of the
people you know writing everyday weird
crazy emails about everything under the
Sun tweet tweets yeah and I don't think
he emails
I mean tweet he's making the presidency
as an institution he's giving it a black
eye
I think because he is so personalized
the presidency when he leaves that
personal aspect goes away I think the
institution remains and I think I agree
with Mara Mara that the next president
is going to be the anti-trump and so
that president will have every incentive
to restore dignity to the office and do
everything and releases tax returns to
sweep yeah yeah I think that you know
that's gonna be like a like a
fundamental threshold thing next time
before we take some audience questions I
want to ask you guys one more thing the
New York Times this spring did a very
short-lived feature called say something
nice about Donald Trump which I believe
was immediately abandoned due to lack of
material let me ask you the three of you
and I'll give you an out here's the fire
escape all built something that has gone
less badly perhaps than you fear I'll
start with you bill
take your time I have so many to choose
from know what Donald Trump demonstrated
is that you can become President of the
United States without being beholden to
either party and that has its upside and
it has a downside the downside is that
the party has no incentive in yours to
make sure that you're a success and
we're seeing that Trump's relationship
with Congress but there it looked as
though for time as though the parties
had a sort of a headlock on who could be
nominated who could win and trunk
demonstrated you can basically parachute
in from outside
and if you are sufficiently charismatic
in his case I would say his charisma is
mostly negative but one could imagine a
positive charisma if you're sufficiently
charismatic and you know how to
manipulate the media then you can get
elected and I think that's a penalty a
positive thing I would say that if
you're a conservative Republican or just
a Republican you would say Neil Gorsuch
and all those Obamacare regulations that
have been obliterated is a good thing
but that's a partisan criteria I would
say you know I actually have something
in mind Oh his choice of his national
security team is a positive I don't
think that he chose them to be the
committee to save America that's a joke
from him but he picked them they were
from central casting they were generals
he liked them but that was definitely a
positive thing just imagine imagine a
world where we had a kind of general
flynn in every one of those positions
instead of mattis Tillerson Kelly
McMasters that was really my point but
I'll also add to I think the last few
weeks on the dreamers and on Dachau and
allowing these people that grew up in
the United States there are our brothers
and sisters to stay here and not be
disrupted now he punted that to Congress
but the willingness to work with Schumer
and Pelosi and try to give some a safety
net a guarantee that there they are
Americans it's it's a bright sign that
maybe he's not so reaching when he's
thinking and operating just from a hard
right perspective with the asterisk that
it will have we will believe it when a
conservative direction on that but you
know we don't know yet we have time for
a couple of questions Harvey relief not
the first trip here to Corpus Christi
but when he got beat up that it wasn't
good enough when he came back into
Houston and hugged people and showed it
kind of a human side to him and I
thought also in Florida now these got
box like tweets later on but they're I
think that he did right during those
disasters and Brock long at FEMA has
done a very solid job but Trump's the
beneficiary of Katrina because after
Michael Brown at FEMA was a disaster
FEMA's reconstructed themselves but I
think we've gotten a degree of activity
out of FEMA that's a lot better than
during Katrina and now poor Puerto Rico
and what's happening there and the
amount of funding they're gonna need and
we have to hope the Trump administration
continues to reach out to Florida Puerto
Rico and Texas that was pretty good for
saying something I think you also read
it very well do we have any questions
from the audience please come down and
use the microphones which are
right at the end of the aisle why don't
you start can you hear me I have a
question for mr. Brinkley so you said
that Reagan wanted to dismantle the
Great Society which I totally yes
but Trump wants to dismantle the New
Deal doesn't that give him kind of an
ideology that I don't see his warranted
yet like you're giving him an intent to
dismantle the New Deal but yet he plays
all the time that you can't touch
entitlements Medicaid as mean I was very
confused by that statement so would just
say that say the last part of it what
terms I found dismantling the New Deal
what's why do you think oh no what we
use not going to dismantle Social
Security or something bent on it it's
kind of a joke but I ended it ronald
reagan's diaries and in reagan's diaries
reagan writes people say I don't like
FDR that I don't like the federal
government well I voted four times for
FDR what I want to do is unroll back the
the Great Society era and I'm suggesting
with Donald Trump now you're seeing he
would like to do away with the Civil
Rights Acts of the 60s he would like to
go back to a more states rights oriented
future he wants to stop this sort of
role of progressivism which culminated
with Obamacare and the Affordable Care
Act which is one of the great trophies
of the public progressive movement and
try to roll back the clock that's all I
would suggest that much ideologies yeah
and see I actually think you're making a
really good point here what you think
that says that oh he has an ideology
where we've been saying he doesn't look
you're making a really good point Jeff
Sessions wants to roll back the New Deal
in other words it's not Donald Trump
Donald Trump does want to obliterate
Obama you're not really Obamacare just
anything Obama did but but the
conservative the kind of far-right
conservative wing of the party that he's
empowered and brought into his
administration that they would like to
roll back the New Deal and you know
Wilson yeah so so it's not so much
he hasn't thought this through he's
allied himself with that wing of the
party who has thought this through
thought this out very carefully and
little by little at the Department of
Justice
Neil Gorsuch on the Supreme Court those
things might be chipped away out but I
agree with you he doesn't have an
ideology as a matter of fact he likes
big government in many ways he wants big
infrastructure programs he loves Social
Security and Medicare and ins and in
that way he's at odds with his party the
Obamacare bills that he has been for
every single one of them are completely
the opposite of what he campaigned on
thank you for in Florida he would love
big government for Florida to help him
with our case because he helps him get
reelected there for years Democrats do
not root for impeachment okay a
light-hearted question this for all of
you so speaking of presidential
traditions and norms in the White House
so Thanksgiving is coming up and the
turkey do you think he's going to hurt
it fire or chop the head off itself him
or his staff gonna forget that he has to
do that the question is will Donald
Trump treat the Thanksgiving turkey like
an apprentice contestant is it more like
a political opponent who wants to take
that one he's gonna treat it like Joe
Arpaio like who Joe Arpaio I think
that's your and I think everybody gets a
pardon from Donald yeah yeah so we don't
yet know how the Mueller investigation
is going to shake out in the end but
even under the best of circumstances
when a White House is under special
counsel investigation there's an
inherent conflict of interest between
the personal counsel to the President as
a person as a practices and as opposed
to the counsel of the White House and on
the one side we have
mueller's team which i learned about a
lot of these these lawyers when I went
to law school and they're the dream team
essentially and then on the other side
we have the clown show of attorneys
talking about private privileged matters
in the air shot of the New York Times so
there's there's gonna be a lot of
conflicts here between those two and
then I get the sense from Trump that he
does not mind picking his own personal
interests over and against the lasting
impact that might have on the executive
branch what do you think in terms of
what are the risks here and how do you
think that'll play out depending on what
happens with the Miller investigation
well I just think that's the beginning
of his presidency he's had the kind of
the heat of the law on him he had people
he's never really been able to relax
because of the Russia probe and it's a
big part of the narrative of 2017 just
when it seems like it's dying down
there's another leak in if when I were
going to write the history of 2017 the
amount of leaking going out of
government is suspending and Trump's
been having to fire people figure it out
stop leaks but they just keep coming out
which means he has a lot of enemies from
within as much as he's picking on the
press all the time because it's useful
politically he has great internal
problems I don't know if he has the
ability to know who to trust right now
he doesn't have an alter ego like
Kennedy at Ted Sorensen or Woodrow
Wilson Colonel house maybe general
Kelley can become that person maybe he
is so he's a president besieged every
day he's worried about lawsuits I think
one of the best comments made recently
is that he's happy in the White House
because the second he leaves he has so
many lawsuits coming on and from so many
things that are it's beyond you know
repair and I don't know how he lives his
life like that where every minute you've
got people that are about to sue you are
suing you but he seems to have lived his
whole life and that
kind of a but world and not been busted
he's not gone to jail on Trump
University didn't get him you know but
he gets people gets penalized he pays
fees and keeps on going but there may be
a bridge too far going on here we'll
find out when the Muller report gets
released yeah I mean look the any kind
of investigation like this is a grinding
process you have people in the White
House having to spend tremendous amounts
of money that they don't have on lawyers
you have people in the White House
worried if one of their colleagues is
wearing a wire it already was a paranoid
backbiting place that kind of
investigation just makes it even more
but in terms of the conflict between Dan
McGann whose job is to represent the
institution of the presidency versus Ty
Cobb and John Dowd who are supposed to
represent Donald Trump as an individual
there is a conflict but if you're a law
student Don McGann does not have
attorney-client privilege
and that's significant the other lawyers
the personal lawyers do and that's why
Bob Muller wants to talk to Don McGann
and get all of the documents that he
might have about about how Don what
Donald Trump was thinking when he fired
Comey but I don't think Donald Trump
himself thinks about the conflict
between his personal legal exposure and
the damage to the institution of the
presidency at all and I don't think he
trusts his our lawyers Donald Trump I
don't even think he tells the lawyers
his own lawyers the truth we could see
that with Bill Clinton during the win
ski things started lying to his own own
attorneys because to let the truth be
known he's worried somehow will leak
because leaks are happening every hour
around him so it's a it's a grim
situation I think the key audience for
the Miller report is the Republican
leadership in Congress if they are
sufficiently annoyed at President Trump
by then that they find something in the
Miller report that they can use against
the president then then there's a
possibility of impeachment but Trump
himself will simply wave away whatever
the conclusions are these are my enemies
what do you expect our Republican
Congress is not going to impeach a
Republican president
I don't pardon
let's squeeze it a couple more man well
I you answered you furthered the answer
about what was what would be the stomach
Turner you know if you paralleled the
arrogance of the German aristocracy and
their thought that they could control
Hitler with the conservative Republicans
and the thought that they could have
controlled Trump my question was what
would be the stomach Turner that would
create the image what would what would
separate the president Bernie when they
get relaxed in 2018 yeah and they
believed that he was the cause or in the
run-up to 2018 they believe that he's a
huge drag on them I think and also we
don't know when the Muller report is
coming out and coming out before or
after November 2018 but I think when
Republicans in Congress see him as a
liability problem right now is that the
base of the Republican Party is with
Donald Trump they are not with the
Republican leadership I did a piece this
week where a Republican operative in
North Carolina said there are three
parties in America there's the Trump
party the Republican congressional party
and there's the Democrats and you see
you saw that playing out in Alabama the
enemy the Republican voters who were for
Roy Morsi Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
as the enemy in other words they even
excused Donald Trump from making a deal
with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer who
used to be the arch villains because
they feel the that McConnell and ryeom
drove him to it in other words
everything is so tribal in American
politics not just between Democrats and
Republicans but even inside the
Republican family and so tribal that if
you're against McConnell and Ryan as Roy
Moore is then that he must be a great
guy I mean it's we have really gone down
the ramp so is there anything that can
shake the support of the Trump they say
for Trump is there anything you can do
to jakka that that I think that
immigration is so fundamental for the
Trump base look he was the original big
birther you know when he started with
birtherism that's how he came into
politics immigration he wrote down the
escalator and called Mexicans rapists
you know when he announced that such a
threshold issue for his base
that many conservatives that I've talked
to say if he does give something that
they see as amnesty to the dreamers even
though they're okay with letting these
young people stay but if they don't get
the wall in exchange they don't get some
really big thing in exchange there will
be not that the base will totally leave
him but they'll be just unenthusiastic
enough enough of them will stay home at
twenty eighteen to make a day that Trump
thought we met with Schumer and Pelosi
the next morning and Coulter report on
the campaign trail regularly with Donald
Trump it yeah tweeted out who now I want
him impeached me and she was sending a
louder message that the hard rights not
going to allow what you're suggesting
Dhaka but on the impeachment of Trump
look it was Republicans that took Nixon
down it was a gang of senators it's when
Barry Goldwater told one of his own no
you lied to me and it's conceivable you
could get a gang of ten US senators if
the mullah report is really egregious
and it looks like Donald Trump somehow
colluded with Russia that you could
could get a movement for impeachment
with repop some Republicans leading the
charge but in the end I don't know if
it'll be more than just a sensor that
comes out of it and in the end they'll
try to do something punitive but I don't
know it just depends what's in that
report there one more really quick
question
I don't know how quick it is doctor
brands mentioned that one of the things
that Trump has accomplished is that he's
proven an independent can parachute in
and if that independent can control the
media then when is the media not
inoculated to some extent now and I
think that's relevant to 20/20 as well
as 24 is it inoculated to some extent
against Trump in his reelection campaign
and will it still be the same if it goes
forward more I couldn't he's a I can I
was really hard to hear the question
something if he inoculated wait doctor
bran suggested that one of the things
that
the president Trump has done is proven
that a an independent can parachute in
and break either part astray on the
presidency and so is the press and press
control was one of the things dr. brand
suggested was critical to that success
is the press not now inoculated to being
manipulated for that purpose yeah oh so
I mean Donald Trump with master of the
media in the 2016 campaign and that was
central to his success so could I guess
the question is could somebody else do
the same thing could he do it again yes
he could he do it again or has the media
why he's done why is that I see that's a
really good question there's no doubt
that during the campaign he was such an
object of fascination that he the media
was aided and abetted him he controlled
the headlines what CNN was famously
criticized for having 45 minutes of an
empty podium waiting for him to arrive
talking about him meanwhile Hillary
Clinton is holding a rally somewhere and
they don't even cut to it you know that
kind of thing I think things will be
different next time I think they've
already changed you even saw during the
campaign the Chiron's
they started fact-checking him in real
time in other words instead of waiting
for him to say something then you have
some separate fact-checking piece the
chyron says Donald Trump says blah blah
blah not true or something like that so
so I think things have changed you look
the other thing you see is this whole
soul-searching among the big giant
social media companies Google Facebook
the role that they played and and how
they can be different how they can have
more gatekeepers and sort out fake news
Russia back news from from other things
I think that it's always kind of a game
of catch-up I think that Donald Trump's
control of the media and his ability to
manipulate it and play us like a fiddle
that probably will not be exactly the
same next time however the the what HW
said which is really filled said that
was really true is that he did disrupt
the two-party system
and that he has this group of voters who
are beholden only to him not necessarily
the Republican in Congress but only to
him and one of the reasons that the
Republicans brought up yet another
Obamacare repeal effort is that when
they went home over break all they heard
was why aren't you doing more to help
Donald Trump why aren't you doing more
to fulfill your promises and the and
that base of voters however small it
might be getting is still really really
strong we will take this group to the
community hub and the Texas Union thank
you so much all for joining us today
[Applause]